In this section, we're going to create a simple light absorption material.
Now within the material, we can control the color of transmission through the glass,
also known as Beer's Law, by using the absorption medium output node.
We can also add a few additional nodes to our absorption medium to control the normalized distance for color.
Now if you recall from the previous section, we used this example sphere to apply our material to to see the results.
All I've done is simply gone into the object itself and just reset our element zero,
which is that primary material so we can see what we're building in this section.
I'm going to go down to my content drawer and in that same examples folder,
I'm going to right click and create a new material and we'll call this one M underscore PT absorption.
It enter and we'll double click and open up this material.
Bring over our window and very much like the last section,
there's a couple basic things we need to establish on the material itself before we start adding all of our nodes.
So by either clicking the material itself or in the empty space of our material graph,
we need to change a few of the material properties.
So the first one on our blend mode, we're going to change this to translucent.
We do want to ensure that two sided is checked.
Now pro tip, you can override this on your material instances,
but in this case we want to have it enabled for the main material under our lighting mode.
We want to make sure that we have surface or shading enabled.
And finally, we want to change two more properties here.
So if we go to search and just type in refraction, change our refraction method to index of refraction,
which again will enable this property on the material itself.
And we are going to search for pixel and we are looking for pixel depth offset mode,
which pro tip if you're not sure what the property is,
simply highlight over the words and it should pop up a little contextual helper.
Explain a little bit about what that property is.
So on this one, we're going to change it from a long camera vector to legacy.
Now we can clear our search should give us back our material and we can hit save.
Now, if you want to, we can go ahead and go back to our content drawer and simply drag and drop this onto our material
so we can kind of see the results as we build it.
Perfect.
All right. So on the main material itself, we're going to go ahead and add a few properties to this.
Now you can, like we did in the previous video, hold down the numbers one, two or three to respectively create a single scalar to scalar or three scalar.
Or you can just simply click in the property here and it will accept it.
It's totally up to you.
All right. So what I'm going to do is just go ahead and create a single scalar here for my roughness.
Plug this into roughness and we'll keep it as something like zero in my opacity.
So I'll do the same thing. Hold down the number one and left click and an opacity.
I'm going to plug this in and do something like point five.
For my index of refraction, I will use one point five.
We'll plug this in.
And optionally, if we do want to convert this to a material instance so we can adjust those properties on the fly, you can pro tip select all of your properties, right click and convert to a parameter.
And then we can start naming those. So I'll just do that real quick and just name them respectively so we can do roughness like this and we'll do opacity.
And finally, we can do.
I or perfect. There we go. So now we can see it still accepted the values we created initially, but converted these two parameters.
Go ahead and hit save.
And it should update our material.
Perfect. Now, in this next section, we are going to create the additional output node, which is the absorption medium.
So I'm going to right click and in here I'm going to type in absorb and we're looking for absorption medium material output.
And you notice it is path tracer only.
Now, from here, I'm actually just going to drag back and we're going to do a power node. So just type in power.
And from our base, I'm going to drag off of this and we can do something like constant and we're looking for a constant three vector.
And for this one in particular, I'm just going to give you the values of the example material, but feel free to kind of play around with this.
So for our X, which will be just our red, we're going to do point one point two one six for our green will be one.
And for our blue B point four one five, we'll do something like that.
Perfect. And then from our exponent, we're going to drag back onto here.
We're going to do a divide. And then in our a, we drag back here and I can just type in scalar and get me a one scalar parameter.
And you notice that if we use scalar parameter as opposed to just a single vector, you'll notice it creates the single scalar
and converts it automatically to a parameter. Just a handy little shortcut.
We can still do the same thing by holding down the number one and then right clicking convert to parameter, which will just save us some time.
All right. So our first parameter, I'm going to call this normalization.
And then we could do something like after a hundred just as a little bit of context as to what's happening.
And we'll set the default value to a hundred. And then for our second parameter,
we are going to create absorb shin. Distance.
And then for this one, it will be a value of five. Perfect.
And we'll do this. And that should be our absorption medium, which again, this is these two particular parameters we can control individually,
which is just controlling the path tracing calculations on the glass through the absorption based on a distance that we're setting with that property.
Hopefully that makes sense. All right. So we'll go ahead and hit save. And then we should see the material update in our viewport.
Perfect. And now you can start to see some of that coloration that's happening with the absorption and we can move our path tracer around and just kind of view the material a little bit more.
Now, to help with the effect, I'm just going to take our capacity down to something like point one, it save and we'll see it update just to highlight a little bit more about the material.
So you can see it on the video. But again, feel free to play with all of the parameters and just experiment with what they do and see the results inside of your viewport.
Now, in this next section, we're going to dive a little bit deeper into our materials, in particular, being able to control some of the different passes through the material itself for some really fine tune power level control.
So we'll jump into the next video.